welcome back welcome back Steven doing
another three Episode bursts before the
New Year rolls in you might be wondering
why we're not driving today hi Devon
Devon's up front driving because we're
picking up our special co-star today
he's an avid fan of the show from River
Forest Illinois his name is Jackson and
his visit is made possible by
make-a-wish what's up
nice to meet you hi guys there you go
yes all right hi welcome to the car
Jackson but worth out of mommy' all
right whoa whoa whoa I'm the punk master
on this show like it Thank You Jackson
for joining us on our double
cheeseburger episode today thank you for
having me you flew all the way out from
Illinois
yeah the Midwest I like you already
should we do the today on worth it
you don't do that today I'm worth it
we're having three double cheeseburgers
three just the different price points
see which one is worth it the most worth
and those come on okay VIN price point
so that's at least six patties are you
prepared I'm hungry good so the first
place we're going to is called burgers
never-say-die we're gonna see Sean this
is a smash brother joint I love super
smash the game ultimate you play a
little mint yes whoa who's your main
Donkey Kong
okay okay I'm an S main you're bringing
all the co-host attributes that Stephen
wants in me but I don't possess hey you
watch the NBA yes yeah that's what I'm
talking about
so your menu starts with the regular and
the regular has two patties yes why is
that I'm like double cheeseburgers
that's what I grew up eating it also
works because it's smash pounding and
tell us what a smash burger is it's
cooked on a flattop at very high heat
and you just smash it down there so it
Sears to the griddle the whole process
probably takes a minute or less what
makes a very good burger it's so
subjective like personally for me I like
burgers cooked on the griddle what does
the griddle add you get flavor that's
been there the seasoning from the food
items other than burgers what drew you
to making burgers specifically my wife
and I we were always really into burgers
and
to the food scene in Bell Lane bringing
together all the burgers we ate I
thought I wanted to try making this
burger myself I started in my backyard
with no intention of opening a
restaurant for a couple weeks of just
begging people to come and try the
burger friends co-workers whoever then
some people approached me asking me if I
wanted to open a restaurant and I throw
my whole life I usually just jump in and
I thought let's give this a shot and see
what happens we have a sign right here
that says always ordered - why it's an
ode to the backyard you know people
would order one and they would regret it
and then there would be a long line or
we had sold out so he's - still doable
I recommend - for you yeah what about
you do you do - are you - I've eaten
like six in one day oh my goodness I
mean we're gonna do six probably over
the course of this day for us so why not
start with - here we go all right
Jackson take it away Wharf it double
cheever take one that's perfect that's
better than I usually do take two that
burgers never-say-die I also have
soft-serve ice cream
insider pro tip you get your soft-serve
in a cup order a soda on the side and
then mix it for your own float where the
correct proportions for a float does
anybody know whole bottle it's a feel
Jackson's got classic root beer float
this is Stevens I got chocolate and a
blueberry root beer okay when one little
one cheers cheers Cheers
how do you eat this who thought it Oh
floats
Horsham soda on some ice cream it's like
some the parents aren't home Cheers
that's right just McDonald's they like
me - who knows
yeah so these fries are fried in beef
tallow apparently this is what
McDonald's tasted like way back in the
day before they switch to a vegetable
oil staying true to their motto we've
got two burgers for each of us except
for you Jackson because this is your
first time on one of these rodeos I
don't want to do that - here whoa it
looks the way a fast-food burger looks
in a commercial but this is how it is in
real life smells good
great bonne smell you know did you think
you'd have to wait this long before you
actually get to take a bite can I point
one more physical attribute of this
burger before we bite into it sorry
Jackson look at the way it's like a
lattice yeah yeah yeah crispy very
crispy but you can almost see through
the meat like a spider's web here's mmm
it's crunchy too it's really really good
G yeah it's the essence of burger
nothing extra there's not like strange
sauces or condiments oh man this might
be the best burger I've ever oh man like
truly what do you pay with that yes well
over 100 you next burger here we go
you'd definitely be satisfied by one of
these but you're gonna want to I do
agree order two Oh what am I doing with
my life now I'm only slightly lactose
intolerant so low levels of cheese
that's fine so you like those intolerant
at all no you're a lucky person
oh we had ice cream - what am i doing
Jackson what do you think about the part
of the show where Adam eats thanks for
the lunch bites
twice what a cheeseburger that was
insane
Oh twins whose sympatico so before our
next double cheeseburger we're actually
gonna get another double cheese we're
going to this French restaurant in West
Hollywood called Tess I saw an Instagram
that for national burger day they made
I'm just gonna call it a special desert
burger we reached out in the pastry chef
Sally so kindly agreed to remake it but
double this time this might be the most
visually appealing burger of the day
close your eyes okay man this is gonna
blow you away
three two one reveal oh it's very
realistic dude is that a strawberry yes
yes to macarons chocolate ganache mango
passionfruit cheese
strawberry slices shiso leaf in a
raspberry jelly for the ketchup Wow
if you did not tell me that was dessert
I would not have guessed it cheers
Cheers
how to eat this hmm actually really good
it means chocolate and fruit what's not
to like it's sweet and bitter at the
same time let the knob tasting notes
coming off a Jack Sammons this isn't
your first time is there are we tired
today you can have that do you know what
time it is now
yes oh that's me but if you didn't know
that time that's right double
cheeseburger fact double cheeseburger
fact one minute bob's big boy is
credited with selling the first double
cheeseburger in 1937 the chains original
name was Bob's pantry but after the
double cheeseburger dubbed the big boy
was invented the restaurant changed its
name to boast its famous burger the
double cheeseburger became so famous
they changed their restaurant name
whoa would probably be called Adams
silent fight Adams big fight Adam's big
buddy yes we're next double cheeseburger
we're on our way to see Fredrik and Max
at Burger Ward's in Highland Park
similar to this double cheeseburger this
next double cheeseburger made without
meat I've never had a veggie
cheeseburger before curveball for the
episode I'm scared and excited scary and
exciting is a good place to be with food
tell us what kind of restaurant burger
Lords is the way I think of it's kind of
a bizarro version of a traditional
fast-food restaurant you used to go
frozen garden burger Portobello this is
a opposite where everything is vegan
vegetarian except the beef burger do you
think you're more popular with
traditional beef cheeseburgers or with
the vegetarian and vegan friend honestly
it's like 50/50 yeah we look at it every
week how did you guys develop the recipe
for this patty everything kind of has
its role the barley for chewiness and
cashews give it a nice crunch we're
roasting all the eggplants slicing up
the other vegetables those get sauteed
with all the spices on the flattop
cooking barley in a rice cooker with
kombu and miso roasting nuts garbanzo
beans cashews and then it all goes into
one batch and just mixed up once it's
cold it settles and then we're balling
it like a traditional burger we roll it
in panko then we patty it out so the
panko when it's cooking gives it a kind
of crispy edge helps keep the patty from
burning on the grill - all of the work
comes at the beginning so we can push it
out really fast on average I mean our
tickets are like five to ten minutes
it's like me oh fast food yeah it feels
like fast food it looks like it on the
exterior but in the kitchen we're
cooking all day now that you've
explained all of this it feels like a
burger joint is the hardest thing to do
for vegetarians like why did we want to
tackle a burger joint you know there's
the nostalgia you know it's the
experience of a diner a fast-food
restaurant having fries and eating a
burger it was also to create something
that we didn't think really existed here
you know when we grew up there was a lot
of times we felt left out so we wanted
to make sure that everyone felt they had
a good option here
so to round out our experience we also
got the tofu nuggets and french fries
lord of the fries style lord of the
fries it's a good pun have you read
little replies yet God can't take you
anywhere
cheers Cheers oh is it good
oh my goodness for the first time in my
life I have somebody who's also a messy
eater look at that she's crying it's got
the cheese crust
cheers Cheers brother bombs mmm good Wow
doesn't taste like punch at all tastes
like beef it's hot cheesy juicy meaty
and yet there's no mean so when you
think man I can really go for a burger
right now does this satisfy that feeling
100% she's you know finished that begs
dude I'm trying to put a little hot
sauce on there oh yeah how'd you ask me
you know what that's really good a nice
little kick it really brightens the
flavor of the burger oh it has a good
kick to it
oh good it is like I'm like in a
different universe right now
vegetarian food in this universe is the
norm just gonna feel like we're in the
twilight zone said just like transported
back in time into an alternate reality
where everybody is a vegetarian and you
know what pretty good here watch father
said wow that's a good bite wife line
like not just mind blowing life blowing
life my gosh guys I'm on the patty
number ten I can't count anyway I tell
them any better than that before we go
to our last burger it's time for one
more burger fact double cheeseburger
fact would you like to read the FAQ
today sure the price of the Big Mac one
is if you Tanisha mind was 49 cents 49
cents so you're telling me I could go to
a McDonald's with two quarters and come
back with a Big Mac and a penny yeah in
the 60s when it debuts oh sorry
66 right we're on our way to Petit Pois
where we're gonna see Chef Ludo and his
double cheeseburger called the big mech
and what is on this big mech well it's a
french restaurant so sauce but it wha
it's a classic French restaurant the
design and the food is very French and
so you have this burger how does that
fit into that classic menu in France we
eat a lot to stay cachet you know the
party so I decided to just do a burger
like what American like you know I look
a lot burger - what makes a really good
burger burger to be crispy and juicy
when I to a steak or any meat that's
what I want I want the meat to be crispy
it's called the Big Mac styled after the
Big Mac of course of course
yeah cause make in France mean guys of
to partner John and V and well as we
make French food is what about the sauce
so was very potent for me to have my
burger in the plate swimming in the
sauce like we neither state so I decided
to do a classic French sauce called
borderless beef stock with
shallowed and I had wine sauce we take
like eight hour to do then after we have
aged cheddar cheese how would you not
know if I were going to put a sheet of
cheese or American cheese because I love
American cheese really what love America
we don't I can reckon she's guys come on
some people don't when I think about
French cuisine I think fine dining or I
think like kind of cuckoo yeah I mean
this burger is now all coming to mind
right my job as a chef it's also to cook
what people want and it's going to mix
you know American food with French
cuisine I recommend with the burger with
a [ __ ] knife very French food is fork
a knife in French we eat a burger with a
[ __ ] knife okay guys sorry yeah we do
there it is
it's really unlike any burger I've ever
seen before look at how I plated it's in
a pool of sauce yeah it looks like a
lily pad in a murky pond we do the
honors oh okay
everybody in there's gonna watch you cut
this in half we're losing traction 2000
cheeseburger you're just hacking through
double stabbed through the whole thing
to secure your bite regret saying that I
would be okay sharing the burger I'm
good cheers Cheers
I'm gonna mop up some sauce it's magical
yeah yeah boy Wow oh man that sauce that
song edible the patty is so crispy is
juicy and crispy same time okay if I
were to go back to Burger Lord's that
wasn't everything I want in a burger
what it's vegetarian this is everything
I didn't know I wanted exactly I don't
think I've had a sauce like this before
that is so rich and yet tantalizing yes
the sourness just makes you crave more
yes it does
Jackson's like keep talking while I eat
the rest is this what you thought an
expensive burger would look like on
worth it no
look fancier most expensive burger is
like your episode with Keef there was a
lot of ingredients like foie gras and
lobster uh-huh
this one just has even cheese in a sauce
it's so simple that you don't get
anything else how is it I can see why
you'd use a fork and knife
so how do you feel food :
the gum so now's the time you know what
time it is double cheese with a dance
time go double cheeseburger Hey
Oh before we get to our worth of winners
what was your favorite thing today that
wasn't a double cheeseburger but dessert
at tes oh yeah it's good you just stole
my answer my favorite thing today that
wasn't a double cheeseburger was our
co-star Jackson oh and the fact that I
didn't have to eat alone with Steven I
think we'll start with you today Steven
which double cheeseburger was most worth
it to you at its given price burgers
never-say-die the texture of the patty
was what I try to accomplish when I add
chips to my burgers crunchy crispy juicy
ball where wine is back you put potato
chips on your cheeseburgers yeah great
double cheeseburger I gotta say my worth
that winner just barely go through the
burger Lords oh the vegetarian double
cheeseburger that redefined what a
double cheeseburger could be next up we
got Andrew I love all of these places
burgers never-say-die probably the best
straightforward cheeseburger I've ever
had burger Lords I think that's where
I'd go if I wanted to hang out with
people am I gonna say my worth a winner
is Petit Pois I think I am when I think
about it I start salivating I think it's
the Bordelaise sauce do you see that
coming
no look obviously they were all great
burgers before I see my work at wonder
how did you not pick the last I mean
you're the Beast of food it's a very
fancy boy you know a hot dog you picked
them high price one steak high-priced
Wow and you actually go back and tally
the ones I think the high-priced one
though like not that all sushi and
burger okay Jackson's knowledge of the
show is coming back to haunt us I love
you too bro all right Jackson okay no
more beating around the bush
it was you're worth it winner so the
veggie burger it was a new
experience for me I'm gonna start
ordering Viking burgers so burger loins
is my work that went it what are you
kidding this was a good fake out Adam
who's your worth a winner Annie who's
your worth a winner
all right we got a good mix here but all
we know for sure is that Andrew lost
today I do not lose this has been quite
the journey thank you for having me
No thank you for flying all the way out
here it was worth it what show name
watch out this worthy winner decision is
gonna haunt me forever so you wanna
change it I take it back it's
[Music]